the phones are on fire already today
we're gonna take some phone calls at 6 1
7 8 3 0 47 50 clearly people very very
interested in chiming in we're gonna
start with our caller from the eight one
seven area code just listen for your
area code you won't really hear anything
different if you're waiting on hold
listen for your area code and call it
from eight one seven tell us who you are
hi my name's Amy member from Harley
awesome thank you what's on your mind
and we're not on speaker or Bluetooth
are we Chris I am let me take you out
okay I thought we might be dealing with
speaker today but I'm glad we're solving
it can you hear me okay that's better
yeah thank you okay clear by his erratic
behavior is abhorrent memory and as
wishy-washy policy that you know he's a
puppet and every sense of the word you
know his policy on any given topic
entirely based on the opinion that's
been espoused to him by the last person
he spoke to yeah yeah we all know that
he just likes to feel important it's the
only reason he really does anything like
this on getting two scoops of ice cream
and everybody else only is one but when
I'm what I'm wondering is he clearly
seems an insulator outside so most
obviously by Russia but also here at
home by corporate interest and the NRA
my question to you is who do you think
here in the United States who is not
tied to Russia is pulling the thickest
string and what do you think their end
game is i I think I mean listen I have
no particular reason to think that
someone like Steven Miller is
particularly tied to Russia like I you
know he's an advisor to Trump and
certainly he's been defending Trump on
Russia stuff but someone like Steven
Miller
seems to really have Trump's ear and not
at least be to my current I'm putting
like 10 qualifiers on it to the best of
my knowledge based on what's gone public
so far I don't know that Stephen Miller
is in a direct way complicit in
whatever's going on with Russia so take
that for what it is Chris but you know
someone like Stephen Miller is who I
would say is really manipulating Trump
outside of a Russia tide horse what do
you think is trying to get out of it
I think self-aggrandizement and sort of
setting himself up for a career of
influence peddling and sort of being
seen as a powerful guy yeah yeah that's
that's unlikely but he's a goober but
whatever
yeah it hasn't it didn't work out all
right for Sean Spicer so far but maybe
for Steven Miller it'll work out better
who knows they work for Bannon either
all right yeah thanks a lot appreciate
it all right thanks actually and in fact
I don't Benin gets pretty good speaking
gigs right now I don't know that we can
say it hasn't worked for Bannon he's
doing well personally on a personal
basis even Miller will continue to do
well so long as he can stay awake Yeah
right he if he falls asleep during
meetings he's gonna be tough to
influence Trump